but we are going to begin with a pretty
dangerous storm dumping several feet of
snow in Western New York and around the
Great Lakes so this is what it looks
like right now in the Buffalo New York
area where you can see driving
conditions or deteriorating quickly it's
a situation that could be
life-threatening for millions of
Americans in some places it's coming
down at a rate of up to four inches
every hour Tanya Rivero reports from
Buffalo which is currently under a state
of emergency
across Western New York winter is here
early and packing a punch overnight a
Relentless snowfall rained down on
Buffalo as its sky is lit up
this wintry preview developed when
Midwest moisture was fueled over Lake
Erie accumulation could be historic
this is considered an extreme event an
extreme weather event Buffalo and its
surrounding areas could get up to five
feet of snow by Sunday that means it's
dangerous it also means it's
life-threatening it's the type of blast
the area hasn't seen in almost a decade
and has alarmed officials enough to take
certain precautions early I'd much
rather Implement a driving ban uh
earlier than waiting for the worst case
scenario and then having it too late and
that's what happened in 2014. eight
years ago Buffalo sustained a three-day
historic snowstorm that resulted in 13
deaths and left thousands of drivers
stranded now just a few hours away this
storm caused Chaos on the roads in some
areas of Pennsylvania along Lake Erie
the brutal winter storm is pummeling the
Midwest snowplows are out in force some
areas of West Michigan already have a
foot of snow this is their first storm
of the season but it's nothing new to
them you can hit any time in November
and then they can snow in April you know
it's just Michigan weather back in
Buffalo they may be used to it as well
but officials are pleading with
residents to just stay home don't put at
risk all these other people who have to
go out in bitter cold weather
so the storm is not just affecting the
roads they remain in really bad shape
that driving ban is still in effect it's
affecting almost all travel in and out
of Buffalo nearly every flight from
Buffalo's main airport has been canceled
Tanya thank you